so hi I'm Sami oh and the Our Lady's New
York Chapter founder you can find us in
our ladies NYC org I'm an RN finance
committee member so a little bit of
Finance interest and I'm also a
quantitative analyst in the public
sector in financial regulation and so
let's keep talking that's my email
address that's me on Twitter I'll try to
if you have questions about stuff I've
done or you have ideas on datasets or
things you want to collaborate on please
come find me or critiques awesome so
yeah so when I first began interacting
with the data science community a Freret
say something
the views today don't represent my
employer they're my own okay so when I
first began interacting with the data
science community in our back in 2015
three things became super super obvious
to me one was I had a lot to learn
yeah just a lot and then there were new
tools packages techniques that are being
introduced constantly which is
incredibly overwhelming even during this
conference I think there are things that
I've seen that I'm like oh I should
learn how to do this ok and then I also
realized that these tools and packages
techniques could make my life
wait-wait-wait easier if only I found a
way to efficiently learn how to use them
and utilize them ok so this obviously
led to more questions and more thoughts
so one was how do I continue to engage
and build a strong skill set how do I
manage this while doing my day job and
how do i connect this back to my day job
in corn finance which is not exactly the
same as data science right a little bit
of a difference so that's why I took the
opportunity in this talk to kind of
explain a little bit more about what I
do because I don't really share that
very often so so when I was thinking
about how to connect this and how to
connect to the open-source community I
did realize one thing that I do read a
lot of academic papers and that requires
a lot of stats encode so I thought hey
what's the easiest way that would be
useful for something I do at work versus
and also useful to the community would
be to replicate what's in these academic
papers so why would one do that other
than just like want to frustrate
yourself so one is to like actually have
it for takeaways right to be able to
read the material and really understand
what it says understand especially when
you're looking at stats code or you're
looking finance code you want to look at
the data you want to see
how accurate those results were you want
to see our accurate the methodology was
so it's really to understand that and
then you want to critically evaluate
whether the methyl the methodology and
technique can be extended to different
frameworks right so because essentially
like a lot of the work I've done in the
past has been in the space of systemic
risk so I want to be able to extend
different methodologies in different
places so and yeah possibly one day
maybe I would be able to contribute like
so many of you here in the open-source
community so so yeah so today's topic is
really systemic risk so yeah okay so
systemic risk is really really important
and it's something that I know most
people look here and they're like oh so
boring okay so basically what happened I
mean there's there been many financial
crises but probably the one you guys
most probably remember is from 2007 2009
and it really emphasized the importance
of systemic risk in the financial sector
and how it is how important it is for it
is for us to understand it as well as
measure it so there were from some
pretty significant landmark events at
the time that were limited not limited
to failures of Bear Stearns Lehman
Brothers Fannie Mae Freddie Mac that
kind of emphasize that you know bank
runs are not really a joke right like we
should we should care about this okay
and there was also a tremendous cost of
systemic risk because essentially we had
to implement all over the world had to
implement policy we had to have parts of
the industry actually agree with this
policy and follow the regulation so it
should be something that we care about
okay so really understanding so what
does it really mean right I mean I gave
you some idea of why the context of it
but what does it mean so ever since the
crisis so the Krait it's been about 10
years from the crisis there's been more
of a collective focus on research in the
systemic risk space and so basically
systemic risk according to the hub the
systemic risk hub generally refers to
the disruption of flow to financial
services and it also can be caused by an
impairment to all of parts of the
financial system and it has the
potential for super serious negative
consequences which we didn't really feel
because our government stepped in but it
could have been really really terrible
so and the reason why this is happening
is because some of these institutions
are very very big and they're
interconnected so it's very hard to
understand the ramifications as you see
them speed along so really the most
fundamental primary cause of systemic
risk is banking crises and to really
understand what drives banking crises
you need to have a really good
definition so I pulled a definition room
in Lebanon Valencia's 2013 paper that
basically meets that a banking crisis
meets two criteria so one is basically
that it has significant signs of
financial distress and the in the system
so as in there are losses or there are
big bank runs or Bank liquidations which
is what we saw in 2007 2009 and then
there is significant banking policy
intervention that's needed to actually
stop the losses so so this this is sort
of like the main idea and so to really
understand the number of crises here's
sort of a graph from the IMF they
maintain an actual financial crises
database from I think 1970 onwards and
so if you see like in 2008 obviously
there were many financial crises across
the world but in total there have been
151 financial crises since 1970 just
kind of crazy and sort of really
understand the cost of something like
this so if you look here um this
actually only goes up to 2000 because
they haven't some of this data is kind
of old so they don't update this as
frequently but the financial crazy if
you look at this it's pretty important
because as a percent of GDP it can it
can add up to a lot so you probably want
to pay attention to what what you know
why of financial crises would happen and
how maybe we can better prevent it or at
least predict it so there we can be
ready for it the other part you probably
want to focus on is sovereign defaults
so you really want to understand
internationally what's happening and to
see whether countries are defaulting on
their own so if you look at the right
the the red the red is the actual amount
of default which if you see in 20
2008-2009 was a little bit lower
actually but there were a lot of
countries defaulting at that time so I
mean it's just the just to really give
you a framework of why banking crises
are an important thing to pay attention
to okay so time to make some more sense
of this
yeah so one of the results from the
crises were to actually have policy
implementation right so you have
regulatory institutions that have been
restructured by dodd-frank if you guys
have heard this in the news lately in
the United States and then there's a
single supervisory mechanism in Europe
and essentially these perform more
macro-prudential like policy and sort of
watch over the system there's also the
Financial Stability Board and Basel
which oversee the global system and
there's been a lot more focused on
having stress tests which is again
something you probably hear that's
talked about in the news and just to
highlight that one of the things that
have come out of the policy framework is
something called Basel 3 which is a
global voluntary framework on bank
capital adequacy stress testing and
market liquidity risk okay so it's
basically a way for people to actually
measure and understand what's going on
and for for the regulate regulators to
actually say okay well you should hold
this much on your books
so now sufficiently bored okay so the
reason why this policy is actually super
important is because in the last 10
years because of this we've actually
started collecting data for the first
time we have data on the stuff that we
never had before right so it's
meaningful okay so the the next step is
to identify the scope of what I was
trying to do so just to remind you I was
trying to do some replication of
academic papers my topic was systemic
risk right okay so so I was trying to
understand the systemic risk measures
more clearly and so the first thing I
found all right the first not the first
thing but one of the things that I found
that I thought was interesting was this
paper that came out about pitfalls and
systemic risk scoring
and I'm not gonna read every author's
name so that's there okay so so that's
the that's the focus of today's like
what I'll show you but if you're
interested there is a systemic risk
effort summary written by Robert Engel
it's out there you can search for it
it's in the annual annual review of
financial economics so that gives you an
update on how we're doing and how we're
measuring things okay so let's start
with Basel three right so this is
basically the set of international
regulations developed by B is to promote
financial stability and so basically
this this allows us to reduce the amount
of damage that banks can cause in the
system so
and really only thirty firms are like
actually designated as stiffies across
the world right so you're like just so
you understand like how big this is and
how these are big firms that are
actually market this way and so this the
score that they come up with in Basel is
actually used for people to evaluate and
tell banks how much money they need to
hold on to so that's why all this stuff
is like you have it everything connects
it's not just the data it's also the
policy and it's also okay so so this
systemic risk scoring methodology I
implemented and what I'm going to
implement and what was implemented in
the paper was actually just the the
official case which is the BCBS and the
Financial Stability Board official
actual methodology now this is it's
mostly simple math but I I didn't see
anything anything on our package that
actually existed that already did this
so I thought it was interesting to try
to replicate it okay so just to give you
an idea of what kind of scores I was
replicating so specifically there are 12
systemic risk scores that focus on five
areas so you have size right which is
basically total exposures of a bank
interconnectedness which is you're
trying to understand how if one bank
fails how does it spread your
suitability which is the difficulties if
how difficult it would be to replace the
service of the bank complexity which is
again the higher the costs the higher
you need to actually fix the bank and
then cross judicial jurisdictional
activity which is banks with
international activities so then you
know they can transmit shocks across
country so well this is pretty important
so these were the these were sort of the
five areas and each each area had about
two to three scores within it that had
to be replicated and so fortunately with
this paper they actually had collected a
meaningful data set because now we have
data I think in this in this paper from
2014 2015 2016 that I could use to
replicate and show the scores so yeah so
so yeah so the other the other part of
this paper focused on actually
challenging the systemic risk scores and
I'm looking for a particular bias so one
of the things that the paper claimed was
that there was you know there was
actually bias towards more volatility as
in more volatile acids we're getting
we're kind of changing the scores and
that that
affects the banks right because are the
banks or the large institutions because
essentially they would have to pay more
right or keep more on their books
essentially so that's that's not they
don't want to have that happen and so
what I essentially ended up building was
a custom package just for myself right
now because I'm still testing it and I
basically used the datasets that they
had which was they had 75 banks in the
world and then I think they actually
extended it to because I had used the
2014 2015 2016 data it was like a
hundred plus banks data that actually
broke down each portion of the score so
I just updated that and sort of
replicated the mathematics in the paper
which I don't think I have time to go
over okay so the packages I used one was
obviously tidy verse because that's the
the easiest one to sort of format data
and none of these data sets are very
very big so I tried to use some tiny
quant to see if I could incorporate
market data but it's not really possible
with this and I used some outliers to
see if there were any outliers and the
day that I could find but my time series
is not that long so wasn't that great
the package I built as you saw it you
Robb's talked yesterday she recommended
using dev tools and used this I had used
that before so so thanks Rob and then
for visualization just for some general
stuff I use ggplot2 okay so just to show
you what kind of what I was doing and
what was the data actually so here I had
the size and the interconnectedness and
all of the measures broken out and this
was the data that I had had from 2014 to
2016 that I sort of looked at the
distribution so it's it's interesting
because there's a lot of skew in size
and interconnectedness up top that you
see towards the towards the right which
I thought was you know like it kind of
gives you an idea of some maybe some of
the bigger banks or some of the bigger
institutions have that score and then so
when you're actually calculating the
final risk score right so there are like
there were 12 12 categories under or 12
set of scores under five categories that
you were collecting when you add it all
that up you actually created a thing
like an actual score that was very
important and that would designate what
asipi is and that would designate the
charge that the city would face so this
in this case it was 130 and above and so
you can see that you know the number
number of banks that actually face that
the actual rank of the bank and you can
see that there are nineteen civvies that
actually passed that number so as and
they are the highest score so they would
face the highest capital charge so I
didn't feel like showing you has many
tables that matched up basically so I
thought I would show you this instead
which I was successful in recreating
what the methodology was so other than
just showing you matching tables because
the math was fairly straightforward and
so but one of the cool things that I did
get through work through this was to
really understand the methodology as
well as the data set that the folks were
using because this data is not really
this is not a mature data set by any
means so there's a lot of fudging that
people do in academic work that you
really need to work through so so I
enjoyed that and then the other packages
I discovered in the systemic risk space
and I urge all of you to come up if you
guys know more so one was systemic risk
which was just an exploration of I think
they come up with trying to understand
defaults and it's through financial
networks and then there was the
evaluator package which I think does a
lot of scenario design which i think is
very cool
I didn't play around too much with this
I just read some of the documentation so
other things I discovered so I found a
really cool I don't know if all of you
know about this the really cool website
called run my code org but they actually
submit finance papers with the datasets
as well as the code that he was mostly
MATLAB because they're really old-school
so it was great to see some of that
although I had a harder time
understanding the MATLAB code but it was
great to see how systemic risk research
has improved over time and then of
course I also found the replication wiki
page that has economics research that's
replicated on it so I thought that was
interesting I didn't get to explore that
too much I use run my code mostly so
lessons learned in this one was that
replicating this work was not as
difficult as I thought it would be I
like what I remember like when trying to
read the paper I was just like oh my god
this is gonna be a lot of a lot of work
for me to try to understand this but it
actually was simpler and it was
incredibly valuable because it helped me
understand the paper and I can now use
some of this work in my actual day job
so which I'm not discussing here okay so
and I also got to build a cool package
and I hope bike
I hope I can go to Iran's talk and make
sure I'm doing all the right things in
it so future work and conclusions I
would like to explore more of the s
Chris s the risk stuff that people have
been putting together on capital
shortfall that's not something I've
really gotten into and then I also want
to find more interesting data sets on
the financial crises so if anyone comes
across something more meaningful I would
love to use it and really quickly
shout-out to Jared for putting up an
awesome conference here and having so
many our ladies speaking kudos please
come and visit us at our ladies NYC and
our in finances next week we're gonna be
covering more nerdy stuff like this so
if you're interested in coming we still
have our it's all open and the discount
code is 11 on 11 for 11 percent off okay
yeah thank you
[Applause]